hello guys this is Antoine Ellie and I'm
Lester green this is unscripted
conversations
this is our first podcast series we
start this series to give the film
community a different view a devout look
our first episodes core I'd like you
love yourself it's also the new book by
that's the green calls I think like you
love yourself and the reason why we call
act like you love yourself because in
the film community I feel like we give
so much to everybody else and we don't
look at ourselves as an actor how many
times you go to the cat's in audition
you put yourself out there get so much
rejection it's just waiting for someone
to put you on waiting for someone to
give you that that opportunity and you
know why we didn't differ every now you
have to wait for the body to get your
own camera get your own crew shoot your
own films so this mattress is for
anybody that's are artists you don't
have to wait for anybody anymore
especially now we have iPhones we have
cameras that's 4k only costs $2,000 so
us we came together and say no way
instead of setups waiting for someone to
tell us we're great zest edit we change
some money that's attract money and this
is a whole series about act like you
love yourself
um let's I got a book quite like you
love myself and he's a he the author he
started his book why you start your book
what made you want to start your book
well I wanted to give a voice to all the
people out there who are struggling
being an actor or just struggling in
life I think the book addresses various
issues that will just help you move
forward in your life and let's talk
about some topics in your book okay yeah
we could talk about the first topic it's
called life is too short right it
started with that because that's where I
met Antoine on the set of his feature
film life is too short and he came to me
and he saw something in me and he said
you know what Lester instead of waiting
for people to cast you and stuff
why don't we come together and work on
our own short film that gave birth to
roll footage
my very first produced short film that's
actually Aaron on national TV right now
CBS to be exact exactly and so that was
all the validation that I needed I
created my own short film
he helped me cast the crew and and the
cast and we were off and running and
that's all it took once I got that first
film under my belt
we haven't stopped yeah and the title
life is too short
it's basically life it is too short you
know you here today going long and I
don't want to die I'm 37 years old I
don't want to die old man full of
regrets there's so many people that live
and live their life better for so many
years they have accomplished anything
right and they don't have that internal
happiness what's the next topic on your
boy Dan the next one is called I got the
power because obviously once you start
gaining momentum and you start getting
your stuff on national TV and you start
getting into festivals and winning
awards then you create that self power
that comes from within yeah and I got
the powers Basin you do have the power
you know sometimes you feel like if I
don't get this big festival if this big
director don't call me what I'm gonna do
right you have to realize we all have
different paths just because you ain't
get your film in a big festival or you
in a big network is other options other
outlets you know being on YouTube right
now movie theaters I ran out on a lot of
datas just show my own film and I make a
nice little income off it so it's just
showing yourself worth and not doing the
same thing when I hit actors or anybody
in the industry that say hey I've been
putting in my work for 20-30 years where
I'm hearing it you waited for 20 30
years I just want to tell you great
Angela Allen created his own film
festival validation so film festival
exactly so he's not waiting for these
festivals to accept his projects he's
creating his own platform his own
festival and he's accepting filmmakers
and actors and producers so that they
can feel welcomed and the reason why I
even start my own film festival is I was
going to a lot of festivals my own first
feature film like two short one 18 Wars
domestically internationally and it was
good but some of the filmmakers or some
of the film festival owners treat
filmmakers like they say nothing so I
started me complaining about how this
film program and take my film or how
this person did is I became part of
solution I think sometimes in life we
complain too much it's the right to
complain but now you gotta do something
so so I start my own film festival
validate yourself the book act like you
love yourself I called it that because a
lot of times people walk into the
audition
and they don't have that confidence or
they're lacking something I think it's
important to walk into that room no
matter where it is if you have a
business meeting or a conference meeting
you want to walk into that room and act
like you love yourself it's all about
how you project yourself how you portray
yourself you want people to feel your
energy
and I'm constantly telling people that
that energy is palpable the energy don't
write energy does not lie people can
feel that and so so important to just
carry that positive energy with you I
recently made a post about surrounding
myself with the right people because I
felt like I was surviving myself with
the wrong people and I'd get a project
done and because the energy wasn't right
it threw everything else off so just be
careful with the people you surround
yourself with and that's a good way to
talk about act like you love yourself
sometimes we have the wrong people
around us because we looking for
validation the people that watches right
now how many times you did a project you
cast this person worker this person and
you know I don't like that person but I
first they have some that you want
whatever you want you can get yourself
and also know yourself worth so it's
times when I first start in this
industry I had people around me I had
certain individuals and I knew it ain't
like them but I had the confidence
enough to be like skeet rid of him just
get rid of that energy you don't lie if
you feel good about yourself and the
person around you is making you feel
good that's the person yeah when you
when you on Facebook and you got friends
that don't comment on your posts don't
like your stuff and you see them in a
street hate me I'm proud of you like
wait a minute I don't even know you look
at my stuff watch out for everything
because I want people to celebrate me
give me roses while I'm here yeah and um
to my to my writers you know I know
you're right allow your strips and
screenplays and you have submit to a
contest is and sometimes you just don't
get in save that little money up and
produce your own ships mmm
direct your own stuff this is the
empowerment podcast series I don't want
none of my filmmakers my right is my
actors feel like just because this
didn't happen or that they happened or
you were a certain color no
if that don't mean anything we in the
age now that we have the power you know
being on film courage you know working
with them on the podcast series
you know we're sharing the power find
great partners well I love about phone
curvatures I didn't have the money I
didn't have $100,000 or whatever the
money to have a sausage go to the NYU or
the best film zoo but film curvature was
my teacher you know I've been watching
film curvatures I've started and I
learned so much from the interviews from
the inspirations and now look at me now
I got a podcast series on one of my
favorite publications so watching this
podcast series I went everybody didn't
know I had like you love yourself let's
listen to your gut listen to your
filling trust yourself more and let's
get the work let's make some films yeah
and get the right actors around you yes
yes yes you know if you go to a film
festival you wanna meet actors you gonna
meet DPS
you go meet editors that's not cool
right there sure just gotta find it
across a lot of money don't spend twenty
thirty thousand dollars on short film
it's a few year filmmakers out there
that's spending twenty thirty thousand
on a short film for what I could do for
short films I can do a feature with that
use your money wisely another thing too
about spending money on budgets don't
throw the bank away meaning don't spend
all this money is one project wishing
that this is the projects or dream
project spread it out we have right now
five short films on a film festival
market we have a feature we have
webseries out there who can we flood in
the market right you never know what
projects gonna take it to the next level
right it's like having a hit record once
you have that first hit you got to keep
going and keep going and keep going
right so you know that's why I have to
say right and then when you walk into
the ballroom this is what he told me you
go in there and you pitch that one
project right and let's say they don't
like it
the next question they might ask you oh
do you have anything else what you're
gonna say I only have one project that's
all I got if this guy walked into a
ballroom right now oh we're not crazy
about that project yeah something else
he has about five six seven eight
different projects that he can put on a
table and pitch so like he said before
don't put all your eggs in one basket
sure you give yourself options you know
give yourself that opportunity that's
another part act like you love yourself
if you're going to meeting with that one
idea you know you share more ideas yeah
definitely and another tip if you have a
web series or movie whatever
I always said shoot it first because
sometimes if you don't have big names
attached to that story it's gonna be
hard to sell our idea on paper yeah give
them the video first so if I have a
feature or I have a podcast series I
want to shoot maybe the first 20 minutes
or the teaser or if you have a TV show
shoot the FIR episode because you're
working that mean they see the video
already just say yes or no you have to
figure things out also what happened
here if you just speaking give him the
vision vision was more easier because
when they look at it and say yes or no
so if you want to pitch anybody
investors networks if there's a
webseries there's a TV show if it's a
feature if there's a feature shoot the
trailer for it if it's a webseries shoot
the first episode if there's a TV show
shoot the pilot hmm you know just to
give them a visual but uh but yeah this
is the podcast series unscripted
conversations yeah that's degree signing
out ants one hour
I'd like you love yourself guys yeah
stop waiting on Oh goddamn people please
go get that book yeah it's a book I hope
you love yourself on Amazon
you